the Taliban haven't won yet many Afghans
want to vote hundreds stand in a queue
waiting for hours to register five years
ago many thought President Hamid
Karzai's victory was a foregone
conclusion this time there really is
something to decide everything seems
open in the more the room we want
reconciliation in our country we want a
government that fights injustice and I
want everyone to vote then there can be
no fraud but democracy is weak in
Afghanistan the Human Rights Commission
is forced to hide behind thick walls it
takes a half an hour of security checks
to get to see masa Mars office she'll be
monitoring the election but worries
about attacks but she's pleased because
the long lines are a good sign so they
are ready to take risk in order to make
the democracy a reality in this country
of course it's a still a very long way
to go but I think it's a good sign most
Afghans want peace and think the
government is corrupt that's how
presidential candidate Ashraf Ghani sees
things even though he's a former
minister himself the former world bank
employee is promising economic reform
and he's optimistic that reconciliation
with the Taliban could succeed we are
offering the ends of peace as is the
durable peace if it's rejected they will
be responsible we are not going to dance
around peace Abdullah Abdullah forced
Karzai into a runoff election that never
took place now he's promising a new
foreign policy like all the other major
candidates he wants international troops
to stay in the country Abdullah says
Afghanistan must sign the security
agreement and the sooner the better he
says the country faces great uncertainty
because the current government refused
to do so signing it candidates elmira
zool was Karzai's foreign minister and
is considered his favourite cars I could
retain influence through him Mohammed
lives in the east of kabul and has no
plans to vote he fled like many Afghans
before him his mosque received a
threatening letter because it had
registered
people to vote but now they're afraid
well card well they arrived I have my
voter card in my pocket but the Taliban
have threatened us if we go to vote they
will burn down our house warrants was
our Giggy not far from his village the
Taliban gather in front of our camera
they warn whoever votes puts their life
in danger they consider democracy on
Islamic but then her but the real
interested in elections democracy has
brought nothing good to our people but
that's why we will not allow elections
to be held in our country Belinda blue
the Afghan seem determined they want
this election there now hoping for a
peaceful election day and a choice that
is as free and fair as possible under
the circumstances